il vient bernard la dent ou bien écoute
bernard à 8000 ans il est crevé on va
faire la réunion c'est lui donc les
poteaux l'ordre du jour de cette réunion
concerne la répartition des tâches
ménagères
parce que j'ai remarqué qu'on ne faisait
pas tout à fait tous les mêmes efforts
dans cette maison non attends écoute tu
n'es pas le seul à être visé mygale mais
tu es un mec cool mais tu ne fais pas ta
part des corvées voilà ouais c'est
peut-être pour ça que je suis un mec
cool non tu loupes l'essentiel tu joues
à énoncer bon tout cas c'est pas une
réunion sur ta coolitude l'isoler ben
c'est une réunion sur quoi la techique
fait est que tu ne fais pas les
servitudes quitte un groupe dans cette
colloque
oui il faut peut-être arrêter de se
voiler la face ça fait 25 ans que c'est
ton tour de vaisselle et a toujours pas
commencé
ça la fout mal quand on invite des gens
chez nous on passer casey on s'en fout
des gens qu'on a vite on les tue un vrai
vampire ne fait pas la vaisselle
c'est comme ça miguel c'est typiquement
le prototype du jeune vampire c'est
vraiment le rigolo de la bande qui fait
toujours des trucs de lire c'est un peu
le bad boys du groupe quoi c'était il ya
deux cents ans je faisais du camping du
côté de la roumanie
j'étais en mode ce cadeau quoi quand
soudain j'entends des hurlements venir
d'un château et là je me dis et si je
mens fuyaient en courant et tout à coup
je vois une créature volante arrivait
sur moi elle m'a trappe avec ses grandes
griffes et elle me ramène dans son
donjon
ensuite cette saloperie m'a mordu le
coup et juste avant que je meure elle
m'a forcé à boire son sang dégueulasse
elle a ouvert ses grandes ailes comme ça
elle volé juste au dessus de moi et elle
me dit à présent je les informe qu'ils
aient ce monstre c'était bernard et on
est resté super pote geoffroy toi par
contre tu as ramené un sac d'os à la
déchetterie ce qui est extrêmement cool
oui l'autre jour j'étais en train de
traîner le corps d'un homme dans le
couloir et j'ai remarqué que sabam ayez
un peu la poussière
enfin c'est comme si j'avais passer la
serpillière je la passe geoffroy lui
c'est vraiment le vieux vampire il a
grandi au moyen-âge
il a vraiment un style très médiéval
c'est un peu notre grand frère toujours
à essayer de protéger
désolé c'est vraiment un type en or même
si parfois il a tendance à être
totalement pervers tu n'as même pas
boire assez qu'on a qu'à prendre des
esclaves quand j'ai été transformée en
vampire je suis tout de suite parti dans
un trip résolument tyrannique
je suis connu pour avoir beaucoup
torture et ça c'est exact bienvenue dans
mon espace torture
je ne viens plus ici aussi souvent
qu'avant j'avais tendance à m'enfermer
un peu dans la torture
j'étais déprimé mon truc c'était deux
fours et des lances dans le postérieur
des gens à l'époque on m'appelait
geoffroy le fourreur alors j'ai mis en
place il ya trente ans ce camembert des
corvées c'est très pratique et mike est
un peu du genre pinailleur donc quand
l'aspirateur est en phase de ton nom
c'est que c'est en année pour passer
l'aspirateur tu vois c'était un dandy du
xviiie siècle alors forcément le gars
est un peu maniaque sur les bords
toujours à nous critiquer là par exemple
j'ai voulu aller boire une tisane au
salon hier soir et il y avait du sang
partout sur mon canapé pompadour
quelques nobles le rouge
oui maintenant il est rousse oui si vous
voulez sucer des victimes sur mon canapé
mettez des journaux par terre ou mettez
des serviettes c'est pas compliqué du
tout mais on est des vampires on va pas
commencer à mettre des serviettes
si certains le font si vous mettez 4
remplir dans une même maison où sera
forcément un moment où ça va partir en
cacahuète
c'est inévitable c'est connu ok donc
bilan de la réunion je propose à
l'avertissement de comportement pour du
gaz c'est toujours pareil
c'est ringard la vaisselle